all right so grammarians i want to talk
to you about the difference between
subject and object pronouns but before
we do that let's start off with a little
primer on what subjects and objects
actually are um just generally for our
grammatical purposes so in grammar the
subject is the part of the sentence or
clause that does
a thing the subject does
a thing
the object on the other hand is the
thing that is acted on has stuff done to
it
so the object has
stuff
done to it
so the subject acts the object is acted
upon let's give an example so
and the sentence
reina
wrote an email
the subject of the sentence the doer of
the thing is reina reyna is the subject
the thing she is doing is writing an
email so rayna wrote an email email is
the object
of the verb wrote it is the object of
the sentence
now there are cases when a sentence
doesn't have
an object
for example we could just say
reina
wrote
it doesn't have an object it's just
ran as the subject
and then there is no object this is what
we call intransitive usage but you don't
need to write that down or anything
now
understanding the relationship between
email and reyna
enables you to understand how subject
and object pronouns are used so when
we're subbing out
these nouns for pronouns
we can figure out which ones we have to
use because pronouns have different
forms depending on whether or not they
are subjects or objects
so reyna is a girl's name and if we know
that reyna is a girl we can refer to her
as either she
or her
these are two of the feminine pronouns
one of these is a subject and one of
them is an object she is the subject
form and her
is the object form
so if we wanted to rewrite this sentence
speaking of reyna we would say
she
wrote an email
not
her
wrote an email
you see
because
her is the
object pronoun
and therefore is the thing that has is
the uh the object pronoun has stuff done
to it as opposed to the doer of things
she is the subject form it's the doer
for email it's easy this just becomes
it in all cases the subject form
and the object form are the same
let's do a couple more examples just to
shore this up so you see what i mean
i give
her
a present
right now i is the subject her is the
object
subject
object but what if we switched it
what would it look like then well it
wouldn't be her give i a present because
since we're switching the subject and
the object we're going to be switching
the pronouns that we use too so it would
be
she
gave
me
a present
now
she is the subject form
of her
and me
is the subject is the object form excuse
me me is the object form of i
get a little period in there
same thing with they and he
so
they
showed
him
a guitar
why not
so they
is the subject
and him is the object
and let's give it the old switcheroo
he showed
them
a guitar
so now
we do the switcheroo him becomes he
so we go from the object form which is
him to the subject form which is he
and then they the subject form becomes
them
the object form
now when it comes to
you and it you're in luck because the
the subject and object forms of these
are the same so subject
equals object
with you
and it
so i could say you give it a present
just as easily as i could say it gives
you a present
oh i didn't realize i changed this to
the past tense she
gives me a present there we go that's
better
and that's the difference between a
subject and an object pronoun
you can learn anything
dave it out